Politico runs the most anti hurricane
Harvey victim ever until Charlie Hebdo
runs another one that's even worse we'll
talk about the all-female Lord of the
Flies yes Hollywood is doing this stupid
thing plus Trump talks taxes are we
actually gonna get tax breaks we'll find
out I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
[Music]
all right another day another dollar
we're here with you and we're going to
go through all of the news of the day I
want to talk at length about all-female
Lord of the Flies because I think this
is one of the stupidest things I have
ever heard that does not work in any
sense first of all there already is an
all-female Lord of the Flies it's called
the view and it blows it's awful but we
will talk about all of the things Lord
of the Flies were related plus we'll
talk about Trump talking taxes and the
left's bizarre reaction to hurricane
Harvey or at least a few people on the
left but before we get to that I first
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at Birch gold so do time seem
uncertain and chaotic if they don't it's
because you're not watching this show
because the fact is the times are
uncertain and chaotic and that's why you
need to invest at least some of your
resources in precious metals that's
where Birch gold group comes in they've
a long-standing track record of
continued success thousands of satisfied
clients countless five-star reviews an
A+ rating with the Better Business
Bureau contact Birch gold group now and
you'll receive a free information kit on
physical precious metals it's a
comprehensive 16 page kit showing how
gold and silver can protect your savings
how you can legally move your IRA or
401k out of stocks and bonds into a
precious metals IRA this is not saying
you should take all of your money out of
stocks and out of bonds but it is saying
you should at least have some of your
money in something that has never been
worth zero and will always have value
that of course is precious metals go to
birchgold.com slash Ben that's
birchgold.com slash Ben you get that
comprehensive 16 at page kit plus that
lets them know that we sent you
birchgold.com slash Ben they're the
folks I trusted to invest in precious
metals okay so I'm really eager to talk
about this all female Lord of the Flies
thing why it's so stupid so I really
want to get to that but before I get to
that I first want to talk about this
cartoon that came out in Politico if you
want to know why there's a cultural
divide in this country it's because even
the things that ought to bring us
together can still be used to tear us
apart here is a cartoon that came out
yesterday from Politico the author the
creator of this this atrocity his name
is Matt worker I believe and if you
can't see it what it shows is a
helicopter with the u.s. logo on trying
to rescue a guy the guy is obviously
supposed to be a Texan right and he is
sitting there in a shirt that is a
Confederate flag and a cowboy hat and
boot
for some reason his jeans are tucked
into his boots I've never met a Texan
who actually tucks his jeans into his
boots but in any case he's there in a
basket and next to him is a flag that
says don't tread on me as he's being as
he's being picked up from the waters and
then the guys shouting angels sent by
God and then there's a house next to him
and the water is up to the roof of the
house and on top there is a sign that
says secede like Texas secede and then a
little girl on top of the roof and a
rescuer who is trying to put a
lifejacket on the little girl and it
says or actually Coast Guard sent by the
government so not angel sent by God
Coast Guard sent by the government there
are so many things wrong with this
idiotic comic that it's almost
impossible to hit them all number one
let's begin with the the caricature of
religious people this angel sent by God
routine okay this is so intensely stupid
I can't even tell you the reason this is
so intensely stupid is because religious
people don't actually believe that
angels are going to save them from the
water they believe that human beings can
sometimes act as instruments of God's
will in saving them okay there there's a
very famous religious joke every
religious person knows this joke but for
those who are not religious in the
audience this is something religious
people tell there's a religious person
joke okay here's the joke and that good
but here's the joke okay the joke is
there's a flood and there's a guy who's
trapped in the flood and so he prays to
God he says God please send me help and
next thing he knows a car drives up and
says hop in dude it's time to get out of
here and he says listen I've talked to
God God is gonna send me help so the car
drives away next thing it happens a boat
comes up and the guy in the boat says
jump in and the religious guy says no no
I've prayed to God God will help me so
that boat motors away and here comes a
low car in the helicopter comes and says
to the religious guy dude jump in lower
roped him he says no no God is gonna
save me so naturally he drowns and then
he goes up to heaven and he says he got
Hey I prayed where were you and God says
I sent you a boat I sent you a car a
boat and a helicopter what do you mean
where was I
okay that's how religious people
actually think of this sort of thing so
this idea that it's angels sent by God
like they don't understand that it's
actually the Coast Guard it can be both
the Coast Guard and also human beings
can act as angels and times of nain in
fact little known fact about Hebrew that
our non-jewish friends probably don't
know the word for of the word for angel
is Moloch in Hebrew the word for
messenger in Hebrew is mala
so human messenger an angel are the same
exact word in Hebrew
okay so just demonstrates there's an
identity here human beings can act as
messengers of the Lord even when they
are acting in pursuit of their everyday
duty so this is this idea that we're all
just a bunch of religious morons is
ridiculous second of all the idea that
this guys weren't Confederate shirt and
that means out obviously that he must be
a racist redneck it's worth noting that
the precincts that have been flooded in
this in this hurricane voted for Hillary
Clinton overwhelmingly overwhelmingly
they voted for Hillary Clinton in fact
the state of New Jersey voted in fewer
numbers for Hillary Clinton than these
districts did by percentage so it was a
bunch of Democrats getting hit by this
hurricane so they're ripping on the
people of Texas as though they are
uniformly Trump voters not even true
okay finally when it says it's the Coast
Guard sent by the government how dare
how dare people in Texas think that the
you know they want to secede now let's
be clear about this the vast majority of
resources that are being brought to bear
in Houston are local and state they are
not federal resources federal resources
provide the vast minority of support
that means that even if Texas were to
see do you think they really wouldn't
have any sort of Coast Guard facilities
Texas a very wealthy state Texas has no
nuclear weapons in the international
guard the idea that Texas is going to I
mean they're under federal auspices but
still the idea that Texas is going to go
completely broke if it were to secede
they wouldn't be able to rescue their
own citizens is absolute nonsense
considering the people who are actually
rescuing their citizens are folks who
are working for the state of Texas and
just because you believe in state
sovereignty just because you believe in
state power under the Constitution does
not mean they're against the the the
government helping you out with your own
taxpayer dollars I mean that's why we
pay for fire services this is why we pay
for the police so this cartoon is so
stupid in every way but what it's really
designed to do is suggest that Texans
are just a bunch of loon bags who don't
understand the beauty of governments if
they just understood the power of
government and the beauty of government
then they would get behind a bigger
stronger government and spend more money
and they wouldn't be these crazy Trump
voters that they are that's what this
cartoon is supposed to mean it's cruel
it's nasty and it's stupid all at once
it's especially stupid because the fact
is that how our Texans acting during
this they're not sitting around waiting
to be rescued this is a picture tweeted
out by a radio host named Michael berry
this is the twelve this is this is a
picture of a bunch of people in
Texas in line can you grab that it's
okay
there it is okay so you can see the this
giant line of people is that giant line
of people people waiting to get services
is that a giant line of people at a food
bank no it turns out that these are
these are a bunch of people in the
center of Houston or waiting in line to
volunteer look at the size of that line
hundreds of people waiting in line to
volunteer those are the people that this
idiot asshat Matt worker is ripping on
in Texas okay those are the people of
Texas those are the people who are
helping each other out
now Charlie Hebdo did exactly the same
routine except more blatant Charlie
Hebdo which is a at least their equal
opportunity offenders they they went
after Muslim Muhammad and Islam in such
a way that they ended up as the target
for for a terrorist attack a few years
back as you recall Charlie I'm Jill ran
a cartoon that showed the that showed a
bunch it says do you exist a I don't
speak French so I assume that means God
exists and they are celebrating the
flood because it's a bunch of people you
can't see it but I'll describe it to you
it's a bunch of hands going up in the
Heil Hitler salute and a bunch of Nazi
flags that are halfway under water
cement of Nazis pour drowned this is the
cover of the magazine is totally
captioned God exists he drowned all the
neo-nazis of Texas again the districts
were a bunch of Democrats second the
people of Texas are not neo-nazis this
is insane the racial makeup of the city
is not let me give you the racial makeup
of the city of Texas according to the
census of 2000 hey its 49.3% white which
includes Hispanic ok 25% black or
african-american so that means that this
is one of the most diverse cities in
America and they're saying that it's a
bunch of white supremacists but again
the left stereotypes have no end here
and they're really quite horrifying and
disgusting and you wonder why people
react by saying that they'll vote for
Trump it's because they're reacting to
stupidity like this it's because they're
reacting to grossing us like this ok so
the truth is that the vast majority
people are not reacting well to these
sorts of cartoons even the left was was
a little upset with with political
revealing the hard left's biases charlie
hebdo's cartoon is not going over like
gangbusters but it does demonstrate the
cultural stereotyping
people in Texas that everybody thinks
that people in Texas are a bunch of
rednecks outside of Texas and that
cultural divide is getting worse not
better
I mean to the point where when Chris
Pratt the actor said at one point that
Hollywood doesn't do a good job of
appealing to blue-collar Americans
outside the major cities and he was
ripped up and down by the left and then
forced to backtrack it's true how it was
just a horrible job of demonstrating
what it is for people who live outside
the major cities because the vast
majority of people who populate our pop
culture are folks who are from major
cities there are people from LA I've
lived here my entire life people from
New York people from Chicago they mostly
come from big cities the myth of the
person who comes from Kansas and hits it
big in Hollywood it happens it's true
but the vast majority of people who work
in Hollywood her from Hollywood the vast
majority of people who write are from
New York or Hollywood the vast majority
of people making our entertainment are
like that and that's why they have such
scorn for people that they've never met
halfway across the country who are
suffering at this time okay so what dad
said I think that also demonstrates now
I get to talk about my favorite subject
the all-female Lord of the Flies before
I talk about all-female Lord of the
Flies however I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at upside comm so if
you are traveling and you need a ticket
fast and you're traveling for business
and you want to save a lot of money the
best way to do it is upside calm you can
look for the exact flights that you need
plus big names hotels you want to stay
out you can buy them separately or you
can bundle them together you can even
add arrive when you bundle you save more
money but not only do you save more
money you also get a gift card to
amazon.com so the way that it works is
that you register over upside comm and
then when you register at upside comm
you ends up saving a bunch of money and
there's on your accounts Amazon gift
card will pop up they have expert
navigators who are always available 24/7
through phone chat social and email to
help at anytime the concierge level
service second to none it's not like one
of these other websites where you go
there you buy the ticket and you never
hear from the people again and you can't
find anybody when you need to and you're
totally screwed if something goes wrong
upside calm gives you the VIP treatment
while you're still paying the low prices
again you save the money your company
saves the money when you buy the tickets
and then on your account pops up the
Amazon gift card that you personally can
use which is super awesome when you use
promo code Ben you are guaranteed to get
at least a $100 amazon.com gift card on
your package purchase with minimum
purchase so go over to up sides out
come and use the promo code ban you're
guaranteed to get at least a $100
amazon.com gift card on that package
purchase again use the promo code ban
you get that hundred dollar gift card
and of course you let them know that we
sent you okay so here is what we know
about when I say that Hollywood is out
of touch I mean that Hollywood is
seriously out of touch they're planning
a movie that makes no sense the
all-female Lord of the Flies why do I
think this is important because I think
that it is important to understand that
the left's perverse and weird notion of
what exactly men and women are boys and
girls is exactly that it's weird and
perverse so if you actually read Lord of
the Flies it is a book about boys
becoming men it is a book about what
happens to boys in the absence of
civilization it is a book about the
violent nature of particularly men and
it's funny that they'd wanted to an
all-female version of this because the
fact is and one of the things that
feminists are constantly ripping about
men is that men are violent right this
is the routine we got from Hillary
Clinton that if Hillary had been elected
president there would never be another
violent thing that happened ever because
all wars in history have been men you
get that routine from the feminists all
the time but now they want to do Lord of
the Flies which is based on physical
violence being done between groups
I guess that now that they've done the
all-female Ghostbusters and that was
such a smashing success and such a
horrible movie and now Scott McGehee and
David Siegel have made a deal on
Warner's to direct a new version of Lord
of the Flies they plan to be faithful to
the novel with one major twist the young
students stranded on a remote island who
descend into a savage social order will
be girls and so here's what they say is
according to habla over a daily wire the
woman David Siegel says we wanted to
have very faithful but contemporized
adaptation of the book first of all why
would you have to do a contemporized
adaptation of the book it's literally a
bunch of boys stuck on an island does
that need a lot of updating it's like
you're it's not like you're updating
Shakespeare or something and you have to
update the language it's like they're a
bunch of cultural totems in Lord of the
Flies literally there is a conch shell
that is the that is the entirety of the
props in Lord of the Flies okay there's
like a pig head that's pretty much it I
guess they can have Lena there the
glasses that's true Thank You Taylor
there the I guess that you could
theoretically cast Lena Dunham as piggy
which might make some sense but David
Siegel says we wanted to a faithful but
contemporized
the adaptation of the book says it is a
timeless story that is especially
relevant today with the interpersonal
conflicts in bullying and the idea of
children forming a society and
replicating the behavior they saw in
grown-ups before they were marooned that
really is not what the book is about the
book is really not about that but if
you've read the book the book is really
not about them imitating the adults the
point of the book is they get to the
island and they realize there are no
adults here we can do whatever we want
that is the first three chapters of the
book have they even read it the entire
point of the book is that man without
civilization descends into anarchy and
violence that's the entire point of the
stupid book and isn't that the book
isn't stupid but this is ridiculous
McGhee he says the subject matter is
aggressively suspenseful and taking the
opportunity to tell it in a way that
hasn't been told before with girls
rather than boys is that it shifts
things in a way that might help people
see the story anew
it breaks away from some of the
conventions the way we think of boys and
aggression we don't think of boys and
aggression boys are aggressive okay I
have I have a girl and I have a boy the
girl is three and a half years old she
is calm she is delightful she's not
aggressive I have a boy who is a
year-and-a-half hoe I love him very much
he is awesome he also will beat the
living crap out of you if you cross him
okay he's a boy that's what they do it's
just about the hacker does people still
talk about the movie in the book from
the standpoint of pure storytelling it
is a great adventure story real
entertainment but it has a lot of
meaning embedded in it as well we've
gotten to think about this a while as
the right to worked out and we're super
eager to put pen to paper so they say
this is just ridiculous
okay a few things about this that are
particularly ridiculous first of all
boys and girls are not the same this is
one of my pet peeves in film it's one of
the reasons I think I said it on the
show atomic glue on fail I think the
reason atomic Glahn failed is because
the character could have been a man and
there would have been no difference to
the story at all like legitimately downs
of its adoption of a woman like there's
literally no difference in in atomic
blonde between her being a man and her
being a woman any movie where there's no
difference in the main character it's
like an action movie that actually
implicates the differences between men
and women any movie that's that focuses
on men and women being exactly
substitutable being exactly the same it
just does not work that way it's it's it
doesn't work for the viewer because the
viewer knows their differences between
boys and girls here's the fact okay the
movie would not work in any real sense
because
rules do not act the same as boys quick
question for you
how many physical fights not like
yelling at each other and then crying on
the phone fights like physical fights
have most girls been in most girls have
been in very very few physical fights if
any a vast majority of girls that I know
haven't been in any physical fights how
many fights have the vast majority of
boys been in the answer is probably
greater than five boys particularly
young boys fight with each other all the
time they have physical fights with each
other their violence is that their their
arguments escalate to physical
aggression in short order in a way that
girls don't girls don't sit around
smacking each other in the face okay
it's not what girls do when I was in law
school there was a group of guys would
legitimately go to bars get drunk and
sock each other in the balls this was
like their way of having fun okay the
idea that that girls like I've never
heard of girls doing this okay guys are
much more aggressive than girls which is
why guys join the army and murder each
other this is why the vast majority of
murderers in every culture in history
have been men the idea that women and
men are exactly the same is stupid they
don't even group the same way you know
what happened if a bunch of girls got
stuck on an island together first of all
they would actually share and talk about
their feelings because they liked that
stuff guys don't like that stuff half of
the beginning of Lord of the Flies is
the guys don't want to share feelings
and piggy wants to share feelings so
they murder him okay so that
legitimately what happens in the book if
a girl tries to share her feelings in an
island with a bunch of other girls were
just shipwrecked they will sit around
and bond over this that's what they will
do okay that beyond that girls don't
tend to break into giant groups they
don't break into giant tribes feeling
there have been studies that have shown
this there was one from the National
Institute of Health that came out just
recently and what they found is that
girls actually like to get together in
sort of best friend forever
circumstances they have a very
close-knit circle of friends right they
have girls will have their best friend
and that's it right guys will get
together in packs and they roam around
in packs that's what they do because
guys are basically just chimpanzees like
male chimpanzees they walk around in
packs that's what happens in Lord of the
Flies they break down into packs and
then they fight each other because men
are looking for physical safety from
other men and so they band together to
provide that physical safety for one
another
girls in the absence of guys are not
deeply worried about other girls
physically attacking them and so they
only need somebody with whom they can
visit with whom they can can spiritually
and mentally
that's what they are looking for this is
why guys don't understand girls and
girls don't understand guys when guys
get angry and when guys get upset
guys get silent when girls get angry and
upset they get very talkative okay girls
actually want to talk about their
feelings they want to talk about what's
upsetting them guys tend to go guys tend
to go quiet and then girls like why
won't you talk to me it's like cuz this
is what guys do guys and girls are
largely this isn't every guy in every
girl these are generalizations but these
general Asians exertions exist for a
reason and are scientifically backed
yeah there's a study conducted by
researchers at the National Institute of
Mental Health and Georgia State
University and what they found is that
girls again like to get together in
one-on-one relationships BFFs and boys
are more attune to group dynamics and
competition that's not something that
girls aren't that interested in engaging
in beyond that boys don't like sharing
right girls like sharing okay this is
according to this according to the APA
the American Psychological Association
quote research has long shown that boys
are less likely to disclose thoughts and
feelings with one another than girls are
popular psychology had posited that boys
reticence to talk about feelings was a
fear of being embarrassed or ridicule by
peers but new research in impress at
child development suggests differently
rather than feeling embarrassed it finds
boys perceive that sharing is simply a
waste of time yes this is correct this
is what men think when people want to
share feelings were like shut up
no one cares okay when girls want to
share feelings they think sharing
feelings make social bonds stronger
girls are right on this and guys are
wrong but guys are right that if you
spend all your time sharing your
feelings nothing gets done okay but this
is why you have societal breakdown and
more to the Flies because it's not a
bunch of guys sitting around and talking
about how sad it is that some of their
friends just drown and how they wish
they could get back to civilization and
how much they miss their parents it's a
bunch of guys going I don't want to talk
about that crap let's go kill a pig
right that's what Lord of the Flies is
so the reason I'm upset about this is
once again Hollywood is trying to
promote this idea that boys and girls
are the same boys and girls are not the
same and people who say that boys and
girls that are the same are super super
stupid in every possible way boys and
girls are not the same boys can't become
girls girls can't become boys there are
some boys who tend toward more feminine
behavior and some girls who tend toward
more masculine behavior but on the whole
there are massive differences in just
plopping girls into boys
rolls doesn't do the trick it's it's so
annoying I mean can you imagine like how
about an all-male beaches I mean as long
as we're gonna be just substituting
sexes how about we just do all-male
beaches you know with like Bette Midler
how bad would that movie be right about
as bad as an all-female Lord of the
Flies
do you really want a movie that Kern
that has in it at Midler and Barbara
Hershey and Mayim Bialik and then
instead you have like Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Sly Stallone they're
just sitting around talking about their
feelings and there's a picture on the
piano of Arnold Schwarzenegger and Sly
Stallone in the poster for the film yeah
I didn't think so either God people can
mean it can we understand that human
beings like watching human beings act
like the actual human beings that they
see in real life they don't want women
who act like men it's one that say women
can't be action stars right if you watch
aliens then you see Ripley right you see
the you see Sigourney Weaver picking up
the man so of what could be a male
action part but the whole point is
because everyone else is dead and
there's no one there to save her right
she has to fulfill that role this
happens in real life too and that's why
that was sy brings true Linda Hamilton
in Terminator 2 she's also forced into
the circumstance like the transition
between Linda Hamilton in Terminator 1
and Linda Hamilton in Terminator 2 is
really fascinating and in Terminator 1
she's very feminine character who's
being protected by this guy who has come
to protect her unborn child right
protect her from being murdered and so
she's very feminine character in
Terminator 2 there's no one there to
protect her and so she has to step up
and do it herself that's not the same
thing as saying that Linda Hamilton in
Terminator 2 should have been Linda
Hamilton in Terminator 1 and told the
guy who came back from the future to go
screw himself she can protect herself
that'll be a dumb movie known and watch
that movie because it'd be stupid okay
meanwhile on a on a less light note
president Trump traveled to Missouri
yesterday to talk about taxes I want to
talk about that but first you have to go
over and subscribe for $9.99 a month you
get this podcast live this magical
unbelievable indescribable podcast live
you get it later without commercials now
you get it on video
plus you get michael Knowles's
interminable show you get that in about
an hour or a couple hours I guess 12:30
you get Andrew Clavin show coming up at
10:30 as well both of these are
excellent shows and you should go watch
them and subscribe for $9.99 a month to
do so also if you want the annual
subscription then you got this the very
finest in all beverage carrying
vessels the leftist years hot or cold
mug you may have been told by others
that it is not up to snuff their names
may rhyme with fleebin cloud er but that
does not mean that what he says is true
that is fake news this is the greatest
mug available this tumbler it's
spectacular and you get that with an
annual subscription of 99 dollars which
saves you a lot of money off the $9.99
monthly subscription do a little math
you saved $20 if you actually got the
annual instead of the monthly you see I
just did that in my head amazing you get
all that okay so if you just want to
listen later go over to iTunes or
SoundCloud subscribe leave us a review
always helps us with the rankings and
iTunes and we appreciate it
we are the largest and fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation by a
longshot
[Music]
okay so president Trump was on the
campaign trail yesterday I mean that's
basically what it was he went over to
Missouri and he gave a speech about
taxes now a lot of people on the Left
were very upset about this notion that
that Trump was talking taxes in the
middle of the hurricane I know people on
the right did some of the same stuff
with Obama so I think it's a huge deal
that he made a speech on taxes in the
middle of the hurricane I don't do I
think you should have delayed it
probably it just it seems like a little
untoward so much but just it doesn't
seem like great timing if you want to
make headlines about taxes don't do it
in the middle of the worst natural
disaster in one of the worst natural
disasters in the history of the country
but do I think it's a huge deal I really
don't Trump demonstrated some of that
fabled empathy that the media says he
has known of in his speech in Missouri
here's what he had to say I was on the
ground in Texas yesterday to meet with
Governor Abbott who is doing by the way
an incredible job and local officials so
that we could coordinate the very big an
unprecedented federal response in
difficult times such as these we see the
true character of the American people
their strength their love and their
resolved we see friend helping friend
neighbor helping neighbor and stranger
helping stranger and together we will
endure and we will overcome okay oh
that's fine I don't see a huge problem
with any of that and of course
everything that he is saying there is
fine and good there are people saying he
seems instance here I hate this kind of
analysis I think it's really dumb it's
kind of stuff where it's like oh we're
gonna read his brain okay there's not
like a huge amount of stuff to read
there in any case the idea that we're
gonna sit around reading you know his
emotions on hurricane hurricane Harvey I
just find absolutely asinine okay and
then he gets into the real tax reform
talk I'm gonna explain what I think is
is right and what is wrong here he says
that this is the opportunity to deliver
real tax reform and he's committed to
working on it so this is our once in a
generation opportunity to deliver real
tax reform for everyday hardworking
American
and I am fully committed to working with
Congress to get this job done and I
don't want to be disappointed by
Congress do you understand okay so he's
ripping on Congress which is fully his
prerogative you know I think that it's
actually not a bad thing for him to be
ripping on Congress McConnell and Ryan's
didn't get the job done on health care
but once again what you're gonna see is
the Trump is running into some serious
problems here because he doesn't know
specifics and he doesn't care about
specifics just as with health care he
seems to be laying out these broad
guidelines and then suggesting that Ryan
and McConnell have to hash them out
themselves they've proved themselves
incompetence at that that means that
Trump actually has to get his hands
dirty this is the problem with having
someone who legitimately is not only not
a policy wonk he doesn't even have a
bunch of people who surround him who are
real policy wonks on taxes like who's
gonna pitch this thing Jared Ivanka
who's gonna pitch this thing Steve
minuchin who is a Democrat until five
minutes ago Gary cone is still a
Democrat as far as I know so some of the
stuff that he says about taxes I think
is correct I mean he talked about
getting getting rid of loopholes and
complexity he talks about lowering the
competitive tax code this is clip 4
we're talk cebause getting rid of some
of the upper tax brackets on corporate
tax rates second we need a competitive
tax code that creates more jobs and
higher wages for Americans it's time to
give American workers the pay raise that
they've been looking for for many many
years
ok so again and that that's about right
I mean everything he's saying there is
correct we do have some of the highest
business rates among developed nations
you know it's that the average business
tax rate has fallen is from says from 45
to 24% in developed nations and we are
at 35 percent corporations pay a lot
less than that in their effective tax
rate but that's because they're doing
what everyone does they're taking every
deduction they're moving jobs offshore
they are moving the money offshore they
are reverse merging with companies
outside the United States they don't
have to pay American tax rates so yes we
have to do all those things he talks
about his sort of theory of how we are
going to how we're gonna bring about
economic growth with tax cuts here's
clip 5 we will lower taxes for middle
income Americans so they can keep more
of their hard-earned paychecks and they
can do lots of things with
paychecks and that really means buying
product
ideally made in this country this is a
theory that's often put out about tax
cuts in general to the middle class
first of all the middle class is not the
hardest hit bracket by any stretch of
the imagination by taxes in the United
States it is the upper class that is hit
by the top tax brackets they are
destroyed by the top tax brackets the
top 5% of income earners let me look up
the exact statistics they pay I believe
something like 30% of all taxes the top
1% is according to CNBC not exactly a
leftists or a right-wing source the top
earning 1% of Americans pay half of
federal income taxes for 2014 that's a
pretty astonishing statistic they will
pay forty five point seven percent of
all individual income taxes in 2014 that
is up from 43 percent in 2013 and forty
percent in 2012 the bottom 80% of
Americans are expected to pay only
fifteen percent of all federal income
tax so the idea that it's the
middle-class tax cut that boosts the
economy is not true but boosts the
economy is people who have money to
invest in the creation of new products
and services actually doing that in
creating jobs right we here at the Daily
wire have created an enormous number of
jobs why because we have funders who are
billionaires who decided to invest that
capital in building a new company and
trying to generate more profit and in
generating that new profit that has made
people who work for the company more
wealthy it's made people who work for
the company more employed you know all
of this is how economics actually works
no one has ever worked for a poor person
it doesn't work that way you don't get
hired by a poor person even middle-class
people it's good that they should have
more money in their pocket that they
earned just as a moral principle but the
way that economics really moves forward
the reason you have better products and
services for the same dollars he used to
spend on an iPhone 3 you're now spending
on an iPhone 7 is because there are
people at the top who are actually
directing those funds toward investment
not just directing those funds toward
the toward the buying of things right
it's actually a Keynesian view the Trump
is espousing there of taxes and Trump is
using the tax issue to stump against
Democrats here's Trump Bosch and Claire
McCaskill who's the senator from
Missouri so we must we have no choice we
must lower our taxes and your Senator
Claire McCaskill she must do this
you and if she doesn't do it for you you
have to vote her out of office the
problem here is that Trump is not really
gonna take a leadership role with
Congress which is what he needs to do he
was elected on the back of the idea that
Paul Ryan and Mitch McConnell are
untrustworthy they need to be led around
like dogs with a leash okay they cannot
be allowed to run the show
and yet Trump is basically abdicated and
said to them you guys handle it and I'll
just go out and stump for it I don't
think that's gonna work here I don't
think that that's gonna be an effective
tactic you know they're a bunch of
people who are Trump supporters who are
upset with him that if he's gonna use
his political capital why is he using it
on tax cuts in the first place and
Coulter has been going after Trump very
hard she says this is a tone-deaf speech
why is he paying attention to Wall
Street why is he paying attention to all
of this we'll explain why corporate tax
rates need to come down in a second but
there a lot of his base is not
particularly concerned with us and
Republicans in Congress it's a question
as to why they're gonna get this
together Senator Mike Lee from Utah he
said listen if we don't get tax reform
we're dead of course Republicans had
been saying the same thing about
Obamacare repeal and they didn't get
that either the American people elected
us expecting us to repeal Obamacare and
bring about tax reform we haven't
repealed Obamacare if we don't get tax
reform done we're dead we might as well
fold up our tent and go home okay well
they keep saying that except for the
Democrats continue to suck at their job
so it almost doesn't matter what
Republicans do in any of this they can
continue to stink at their jobs and
nothing major will happen now what's
interesting is that the Democrats in
stinking at their jobs have come down
along two lines one version of the
Democrats they say let's hold our fire
let's keep let's let's keep our powder
dry let's wait till Trump makes a big
boo-boo and then we can jump on him with
both feet and the other group of
Democrats are the people who are still
rabid over the last election and they
are interested in tearing down from
everyday Dianne Feinstein who's a much
more clever Democrat than most of them
she's my senator out here in California
I think she's a garbage senator but
she's a clever woman and here's what she
had to say about President Trump that
kind of shocked her own constituents
when she was doing an event out here in
California
look this man is going to be president
most likely for the rest of this term I
just hope he has the ability to learn
and to change and if he does he can be a
good president and that's my hope
okay so she said she hopes he's a good
president this is an asthma for a lot of
people on the left but she's smart by
saying this it allows her to draw
distance from him when he actually does
something wrong it sounds like she's
propping him up but she's just gonna
kick that that crutch away as soon as it
becomes convenient to do so this is the
smart version of what Democrats are
doing here's the dumb version of what
Democrats are doing Richard Trumka the
head of the afl-cio says that he would
support Trump except the Trump's a
horrible terrible no good very bad
racist he had two factions in the White
House
you had one faction that actually had
some of the policies that we would have
supported on trade and infrastructure
but they turned out to be racist and on
the other hand you had people that
weren't quite what racist but they were
Wall Streeters okay so the idea that all
the people he was he was trying to do
business with they were all a bunch of
terrible horrible racist again it's kind
of funny hearing this from a lot of
these unions like the afl-cio there are
major Union issues in the first part of
the 20th century and most of the
twentieth century actually in which the
unions would not allow black people to
join because it was considered a union
against a lot of the freed slaves who
were going to swamp the labor market
that's what the Union was designed to do
actually for example the pullman car
strike in the in the late 19th century
was designed to keep black people out of
jobs so it's funny to hear the unions
talk about their their lack of racism
okay so I want to get to some things I
like and then some things I hate and I
want to get to the big idea today
because today is a Thursday which means
we talked about a big idea okay so let's
do some things that I like so the thing
that I like today I've been talking
philosophy all week I stumbled on this
new podcast that's been featured over at
iTunes and I really really enjoy it it's
called philosophize this and the guy who
hosts it is not a university professor
his name is Stephen West he is a guy who
really knows how to bring the the
philosophers sort of down to root level
you don't have to have a PhD in order to
listen to this podcast and understand it
he goes through all of the major
philosophers discusses their major views
in a really user-friendly way I really
enjoy this podcast I think that it's
really terrific I actually reached out
to him
it was it was it was kind of funny I
reached out to him just to tell him I
enjoyed his work I do this a lot with
with folks whose work I enjoy and and he
actually wrote back and said I listened
to your show to big fan so so thank
Stephen I appreciate it go give it a
listen it's a really good education and
if you look at the episodes then you
will see that he goes through everything
from Marx right now he's doing the
Frankfurt at school actually so that may
that's pretty fascinating
he's talked about ein Rand he's talked
about Sartre he's talked about Aristotle
he goes all the way back to the
beginnings of Western history he goes
into Eastern philosophy talks about
Heidegger I mean it's just it's it's
really eclectic and he's done a really
good job I think popularizing what are
some pretty abstruse philosophies as I
said yesterday about reading some of
these philosophers in their original
language or at least translations is
that their most of our really crappy
writers a lot of them really don't know
how to write very well at all and so
sometimes you're better off hearing a
good summary from somebody who's read
them and understands them and that's
what this this podcast is highly
recommended philosophize this okay other
things that I like so as you recall
there was a white supremacist neo-nazi
guy named Christopher Cantwell you
remember him we talked about him after
the Charlottesville attacks there was
tape of him talking to this reporter
from Vice with enormous glasses in which
Christopher Cantwell described his point
of view on life I'm here to spread ideas
talk in the hopes that somebody more
capable will come along and do that
somebody like Donald Trump who does not
give his daughter to a Jew so Donald
Trump Italy Maurice a lot more racist
than Donald Trump I don't think that you
could feel about race the way I do and
watch that Kushner pet walk around with
that beautiful girl we're here obeying
the law we're doing everything that
we're supposed to do trying to to
Express
and the criminals are over I get in
their way and that is a that is a
foundational profit our society and
whatever you think of my opinions that's
gonna be something that puts you in
danger yeah and that is because this
city is run by Jewish communists
incredible this guy you know really
really just a charming fella so
yesterday he did an interview with The
Daily Beast and here's what he said when
I come down here for a permitted
demonstration championed by the ACLU
where the police are supposed to be
clearing our enemies for our path and
then I find myself involved in a riot
facing 20 years in prison I got
emotional shockingly enough one minute
I'm an effing white supremacist
terrorists in the next minute I'm an
effing cry berry crybaby
I'm a GD human being so the reason that
I put this in things I like rather than
things I hate is because I think there
is something to this when I say there's
something to this I don't mean that he's
a victim I mean that bad people are
human beings we have a tendency as human
beings to take people who we think are
absolute crap human beings and say
that's a monster that person is a
monster
you notice on the show I never call
people monsters the reason I don't call
people monsters is because monsters
don't exist okay there are evil people
but there's still people and the reason
that that's an important distinction is
because we should all recognize that
deep down in the cockles of our little
hearts we all have the capacity for evil
which is why we have to constantly be
examining ourselves are we doing things
because we think that they're actually
for doing good purposes are we treating
people as means rather than ends are we
looking at the world in the most
rational possible way or are we just us
are we attempting to just justify our
own nasty biases about other people in
order to justify the actions that we
take right we all have the capacity I
mean it's sad to say this but we all
have the capacity to become somebody
like Christopher Cantwell one of the
things that drives me absolutely up a
wall is whenever people discuss the Nazi
period they suggested they treat it as
though it was like a collective
psychosis just came over Germans like
they were just sitting there one day and
then boom I mean asthma of insanity hit
the German people and they were all
Nazis murdering Jews
that's not how evil works okay it didn't
work that way in the Soviet Union it
didn't work that way in Germany there
are a lot of people who you would
consider very good who went along with
Hitler because they thought they were
doing the right thing for their country
there are a lot of very good people who
went along with the Confederacy because
they thought that they were doing the
right thing and it's
they were believing something really
evil in order to justify their own
behavior everyone has the capacity to be
evil okay this is the difference between
the religious and by the way scientific
worldview and the sort of post
enlightenment rationalistic secular
humanist worldview the post rash the the
post enlightenment worldview of the
secular humanist is that human beings
were created to do good it's only our
circumstances our social environment
that has made us bad if we weren't for
that social environment we would have
the capacity to rise to the stars
the religious worldview says we are born
essentially sinful creatures there are
limitations to our good well we can try
to overcome them the Jewish view is that
your that your good side in your bad
side are basically fighting it out there
something called the HR Hara which is
your desire to do evil and then there's
your Yeats or hatov which is your desire
to do good and those are in constant
conflict with one another you know that
notion is a lot closer to the scientific
notion of what human beings are we are
not blank slates as John Locke actually
thought we are much more akin to the the
sort of pre-written vehicles that David
Hume or or Immanuel Kant talked about
these these folks who who thought that
we were we were stamped with the
imprimatur of nature and and God and
that means that we are capable of both
good and evil we can all become this
piece of garbage okay he is a human
being he is a human being that's not a
recommendation for him it's a warning to
us
okay the label human being isn't a
recommendation of evil human beings it's
a warning to us that we can become an
evil human beings so that's why I put
this in things I like okay time for a
couple of things that I hate so Michael
Eric Dyson who I believe is a professor
over at Georgetown he was giving a
speech yesterday and once again he's
trotting out this this same nonsense
they say about Mitt Romney that if
Donald Trump doesn't like you it's just
because you're black so you suggest that
Donald Trump doesn't like Barack Obama
not because he disagreed with Barack
Obama or thought he was a bad president
but because he hated the fact that a
black man was in charge the reason we
are here is to remind this nation
that God is still on the throne that no
matter how much power you think you got
you ain't God now then let's be real we
ain't said much about it today but we
know part of the problem going on now is
cause one guy in office hated the guy
who came before him you just met a Negro
was in charge the anti blackness that we
see manifests with lethal ferocity and
troubling reality is mirrored in the
fact that he just hate the fact that a
black man was in charge smarter than you
tired of his nonsense maybe Trump just
didn't like Obama but he didn't like
Obama he doesn't like lots of people
this attempt by the left to paint
everything is racist including the
things that Republicans hate everything
Republicans hate is because of racism it
has its natural outcome in cartoons like
that idiotic cartoon that you saw
Politico or the one from Charlie Hebdo
if you disagree with Michael Eric Dyson
it's because you must not like having a
black guy in charge not cuz you thought
Obama was a crappy president ok I want
to get right to the big ideas before we
run out of time here so I want to talk
about taxes and why it is imperative to
lower taxes okay so this is something
called the Laffer curve there's a very
famous thing I'm gonna explain to you
what this means okay basically the
Laffer curve which is something that an
economist named art Laffer basically
drew up on back of a napkin to show to
the Reagan administration and this
became sort of their guiding policy what
he said is if you are there's tax right
zero to a hundred percent and then
there's tax revenue how much the
government takes in if you go to zero
percent the government takes in zero
dollars right because if you take zero
percent of anybody's income the
government has no money if you take 100
percent of everybody's income the
government also has zero dollars because
people just stop producing why would you
produce for a government that's just
gonna take your money anyway without
compulsion that's what the Laffer curve
shows so he says is there some point in
the middle of that curve where you reach
maximum possible tax revenue brought
into the government and what you see is
that historically speaking every time
taxes are dramatically decreased income
to the government revenue to the
government goes up so when tax rates
were slashed from matically during the
1920s dropping from over 70 percent it's
less than 25 percent personal income
revenues increased substantially
revenues rose from 719 million in 1921
to 1.1 64 billion in 1928 an increase of
61 percent in the sixties same thing
John F Kennedy lowered tax rate
reductions moved the top tax rate down
from 90 percent to 70 percent tax
revenues climbed from 94 billion in 1961
to 153 billion in 1968 an increase of 62
percent still 33 percent increase after
adjusting for inflation under the Reagan
tax cuts the the tax revenues received
by the government rose from 517 billion
to 909 billion in 1988 that's because
the Laffer curve right the idea is that
we're too far over toward the right side
of this chart both is behind me the left
side of this chart we're too far over
toward the left side of this chart and
therefore we have to move back toward
the place labeled T and that's almost
always true because the government is
always going to be on the side of taking
too much revenue not too little the
problem with the Laffer curve is that
people have begun using the Laffer curve
as an excuse for what tax rates ought to
be well you see a lower tax rate would
be better because the government can
then take in more money okay the Laffer
curve is a defensive argument for
conservatives not an offensive argument
the argument in favor of lowering taxes
is not we want the government to have
more money the argument in favor of
lowering taxes that you deserve to keep
your own money because you're gonna use
your money better than the government
will and then if somebody says well
that's gonna lower the amount of money
the government has to spend then you say
well no not necessarily if you move the
tax rate down the government can still
take in more money because the god of
the economy grows as a whole but people
have started using this on the right as
an offensive argument you see we should
lower taxes because then the government
can take in more money the problem with
this is the Democrats always have the
easier argument which is they say well
what if we just what if we're actually
below that point T or if we just move
the point T up well if we just move the
tax rate up because maybe we're actually
on the wrong side of this curve maybe if
we move the tax rate up then we'll hit
the point where we've reached maximum
government revenue so this is a
defensive argument not an offensive
argument to be used but the idea that
lowering taxes inherently leads to
deficits is not true long run and the
short term it's true because anytime you
lower the amount of money that you're
taxing from people in the next year
you're gonna get less money but over the
next five years you will get more money
because the pie itself will expand this
is what they call dynamic scoring when
you hear people talking about
Congressional Budget Office views of how
the economy is going to go over the next
ten years Democrats like to use they
call static scoring assume that the
economy stays exactly the same
and Republicans like to use dynamic
scoring assume that the economy is going
to shift and grow as a result of the
economic policies that we take today so
there's a little bit of background on
the Laffer curve so when you hear people
talk about it now you know what the
Laffer curve is why it's important and
what exactly it means okay we'll be back
here tomorrow with all the latest
updates and we'll do the mailbag i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]